quand on regarde la télé quand on écoute
les gens parlaient on voit qu'ils se
donnent vraiment beaucoup de mal voici
sept ans
bonsoir satan tu viens d'où je viens
d'où wen en faire c'est où l'enfer s'est
partout le faire partout l'enfer est ici
l'ours est partout partout c'est chez
moi non non il faut pas imaginer c'est
pas des flammes c'est pas des fourches
donc faire cesser ses larmes ça peut
être très bien mais très bien là non
mais je suis pas pour le mal des gens et
moi je suis pour le plaisir des gens
pour bien pourquoi vincent moi je suis
sexe pouvoir argent si l'enfer c'est
partout que ses inventeurs rien laisser
dieu inventé moi je m'en sers tu veux
c'est comme ça que ça marche chacun son
boulot et au moment où je t'ai demandé
de venir dans cette émission qu'est ce
que tu disais je priais je priais je
priais pour que dieu existe parce que si
dieu n'existe pas pas moi je disparais
vallée un truc de 20 de faire chier
quand même celle ci date non parce que
là pour une fois ils sont tous mis
d'accord toutes les chaînes en même
temps le même soir en mairie et non non
tu penses pas que le sida c'est moi par
hasard c'est le sida c'est pas moi même
si c'est toi mais non le sida c'est pas
moi et pourquoi ça donne quoi on le dit
ici là c'est une punition divine
blasquiz qu'est ce qui est contre le
préservatif peut pas le pape le pape est
contre le préservatif et moi je dit
mettez des capotes
jeudi rappelez-vous les eaux sur les
eaux
wen jeudi tirées des pics ou à la
sauvette
l'adultère
dans les ascenseurs
non pas le cabba mais justement il ya un
truc que tu as inventé c'est l'alcool
oui l'alcool je suis pour les tabacs des
comptes oui ces raccourcis la vie même
pas une petite cigarette appel à moi ah
non ça rime à rien la cigarette après
l'amour votre truc à faire après amour
mais qu'est ce que tu fais toi après
l'amour je recommence et après je
recrutement mais après je raconte mais
après 3 commence
vous fumez vous vous faites amour vous
aussi suicide c'est toi le suicide ouais
donc inventer de suicide quand même non
j'aime pas les gens qui arrivent en
avance et les vieillards
j'aime pas non plus les gens qui
arrivent en retard l'homme c'est l'heure
donc tu éviter le mot sexualité tuer
pour prêt pour
ses meilleurs moyens de contraception il
ya un truc que je vais à rome un [ __ ]
ouais
y a un truc je t'emmerde et quand même
c'est les vaccins
faire le mariole là les vaccins non ça
soigne les gens les boxeurs mais oui
mais max et moi qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un vaccin à maxence et du mal que tu
un gect dans le corps des humains donc
ils vivent plus longtemps c'est moi
maxence et moi ça y est vous ça
s'arrange sécher avant tout récemment
donc reprendre leur vie normale
corruption
adultère lice ont tous genres un
mensonge magouilles politiques non
l'apesa du bon si les sdf c'est pas mal
cet hiver oui mais ça y est maintenant
se dépasser pour tourner la page c'est
l'heure d'été non non j'en suis aux
incendies forêts ça c'est des ordures et
le sado maso le retour du sado maso
pas bon pour moi sera normalement ça
devrait être un truc à toi ça oui mais
ils prennent des bof quand il est chez
moi ils sont blasés c'est mais si tu
n'existais pas vous emmèneriez ça serait
triste à mourir serait comme une
cérémonie des molières en plus chiant
wallemme alias rien à voir avec le
diable oui
et non tout s'est tu pourrais travailler
pour moi vous êtes dur j'ai un boulot
mais ça y est tu vois bien il m'a refilé
une émission c'est vrai c'est moi ah
mais ça m'intéresse si tu pourrais
travailler pour moi je vais être direct
auront beau jeu de dire moi je crois que
quand je dis pas que c'est un collectif
je dis que je vais être dur affronter
vrai nom d'un point faible non tu as
besoin fort non le voilà un
autre
là
[Musique]
marion de rein chez toi ça va partir
pas porter une arme facile pourtant sur
des pieds tout en rage les chats
la touche pas
[Musique]
s'appelle comment
fais
[Musique]
je me baladais avec toi
parce que deux mignons qui rit une paix
beaucoup tu me lemaire absolument
fallait partir avec sa femme
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus